now that I'm by the river I can catch  some fish for dinner I don't have a hook  or line with me but the Rara Marie know  how to get everything they need from the  plants I can get my fishing line from an  agave you can take these spikes careful  not to go through your tongue  sighs percise this is way way stronger  than cotton thread I can take this if I  put a little bit of a twist into it  it'll make it about four times stronger  I can't break it  that's amazing how strong it is for  hooks the Rara Marie use another plant a  black tipped agave what I'm after he's  really hard  woody Barb's  there we go the ground near the river is  crawling with insects so I have lots of  bait and my lines in for just a few  minutes when I get a bite  just a little catfish there it doesn't  really matter if it's a big one or a  small one  all fish or protein  [Music]  Oh